c'est chirac bonjour bonjour ça cela
fait vingt ans que tous les hommes
politiques nous disent que les choses
vont changer
pourquoi cette fois ci on devrait vous
croire parce que cela fait vingt ans que
j'écoute que je dialogue avec les
français et que je crois avoir bien
compris ce qui était nécessaire la
france est une grande nation qui
traverse une grave crise et il faut
aujourd'hui qu'elle rassemble ces
énergies qu'elle renforce sa solidarité
qu'elle retrouve son esprit de conquête
si elle veut surmonter ses difficultés
et ça elle peut le faire car dans tous
les moments difficiles dans toutes les
crises de son histoire
elle a trouvé en elle même dans la
confiance qu'elle se portait à elle même
la force nécessaire pour surmonter la
crise mais pour ça il faut vraiment
changer
d'où ma conviction
m